Киянка Ольга Cухопара живе на Лівому березі все життя.
Вона щоденно спостерігає, як розбудовується її район.
Активне будівництво почалося десь в 2000.
Воно спочатку починалося не 25-поверхівками, а в районі 20 поверхів.
Тоді вже здавалося, що це дуже високо
в порівнянні з 10- і 16-поверхівками, які були раніше.
Зараз ми бачимо суцільні 25-30 поверхів, мікрорайонну забудову,
від якої вже давно відмовилися в Європі,
хоча вона в принципі починалася там. А у нас це досі продовжується.
І це не європейська практика, а скоріше радянський спадок,
який ми досі продовжуємо тут створювати.
За оцінками найбільшої у світі бази даних хмарочосів Skyscrapers,
Київ посідає перше місце у Європі за кількістю висотних будівель
- тих, які мають понад 12 поверхів або вищі за 35 метрів.
Окрім висотності, Ольгу бентежить, що забудовники здебільшого
не дбають про розвиток інфраструктури.
Брак місць у садочках і школах, а також недостатня кількість
зелених зон - наслідки активної розбудови району.
Більшість забудовників, на жаль, дійсно не дбають,
щоб створювати нормальні зони відпочинку для своїх клієнтів,
інвесторів, які купують житло. Озера у нас швидше засиплять,
ніж зроблять навколо нього парк і збережуть
водойму для прогулянок мешканців.
Щоб відстоювати право на комфортне життя,
кияни об'єднуються в громадські організації.
Однак коли зусиль окремих ГО стає недостатньо,
відбуваються такі події як Марш за Київ.
Представники понад 40 громадських організацій зібралися,
щоб висунути владі свої вимоги. На марші лунали заклики
щодо збереження історичних пам’яток, водойм і парків,
покращення громадського транспорту та інших проблем,
які роблять життя містян нестерпними.
Проте одна з перших вимог - припинення
“забудовного насильства над містом”.
Люди почали вибудовувати довіру і об'єднуватися для спільної боротьби.
Тому що складно протистояти забудовнику, у якого ресурси,
доступ до медіа і великий фінансовий інтерес, коли у тебе громада з 50 людей.
Але набагато простіше протистояти цьому свавіллю,
коли у вас сила, коли ви об'єдналися і коли у вас є чітко
артикульовані вимоги. От, власне, сьогодні зародження цієї сили,
сили містян, ми можемо спостерігати.
Ольга Сухопара також долучилася до Маршу за Київ.
У нас багато локальних проблем. Коли у вас під будинком вилізла
чергова незапланована новобудова, у вас був невеличкий скверик.
А потім цей клаптик комусь відвели і перед вашим вікном
з'явилася 20-поверхова свічка.
Присутні на марші екоактивісти виступали здебільшого
проти забудови зелених зон міста. Учасники ГО "Екопарк Осокорки",
до прикладу, борються за збереження найбільшого парку
Дарницького району. Нині парк під загрозою забудови
48-ма багатоповерхівками.
На першій ділянці, великій, планується побудувати
2 млн квадратних метрів житла. Це означає, що Південний міст
остаточно стане, під'їзд до Південного моста також стане.
Це просто означатиме колапс транспортної і соціальної інфраструктури.
Це означає, що кияни лишаться такої неймовірної зеленої зони.
І при цьому погіршиться екологічна ситуація як Дарницього району,
так і всього Києва.
Активісти "Екопарку Осокорки" вважають, що Київська міська рада
упереджено ставиться до конфліктів між мешканцями
району і забудовниками.
Ставлення з міською владою мінливе. Останнім часом стало гірше,
тому що забудовне лобі має великий вплив на міську адміністрацію.
Зокрема активісти вважають, що навіть Постійна комісія Київради
з питань екологічної політики протягує рішення на користь
девелоперів, а не місцевої екології.
Голова комісії звинувачення заперечує.
Ситуація не чорно-біла. Екопарк Осокорки створений.
Там ніхто нічого не відбирав і не відміняв. Минулого тижня на комісії
ми розглядали можливість продовження і розширення заповідання цих територій.
Справді, члени екологічної комісії проголосували за надання статусу
об’єктів природно-заповідного фонду озеру Мартишів, розташованому
на території екопарку Осокорки. Однак екопарк має ще два озера,
довкола яких у будь-який момент може відновитися будівництво.
Мер Києва, Віталій Кличко, також відреагував на заклики протестувальників.
У дописі на Фейсбуці він зауважив, що місто вже робить багато з пунктів,
які вимагали виконати учасники «Маршу за Київ».
Натомість депутат Київської міської ради і член Постійної комісії
з питань архітектури, містобудування та земельних відносин Григорій Маленко
визнає, що проблема забудови існує.
Однак вирішити її радикально, запевняє депутат, неможливо.
На сьогодні дуже тяжко витримати баланс. Ми розуміємо, що
неможливо просто взяти і припинити будівництво. Це точно хибний шлях.
З іншого боку, я вважаю, що ми не можемо далі будувати
30-поверхівки без інфраструктури. Моє бажання, щоб цей баланс був.
Але є перекоси.
На думку Маленка, "перекоси" в депутатському корпусі зараз
на користь принципу суцільної забудови. Депутат Київради називає
це "війною світоглядів". Маленко розробив проєкт рішення,
який міг би зобов’язати забудовників більше дбати про інфраструктуру
нових житлових кварталів.
Якщо ви будуєте житло в рамках ДПТ (детальний план території),
будь ласка, чи особисто, чи в співпраці з містом забезпечте
пропорційний розвиток інфраструктури
- садочки, школи, лікарні, сквери.
Наразі ж влада Києва нібито не має впливу на забудовника.
Однак саме влада має вплив на містопланування, зауважує архітектор Влодко Зотов.
На його думку, проблема не у висотності будівель чи хаотичності
нових житлових кварталів, а у монофункційності більшості районів міста.
Нецентральні округи міста не мають розвинутої інфраструктури
- просторів для відпочинку, мистецьких майданчиків, закладів навчання.
Мешканці використовують ці райони з однією метою
- бути вдома. Звідси і їхня назва - спальні.
Місто планується монофункційне. Тут ми будемо спати, тут ми будемо працювати.
Де ходити в дитячий садок і школу, взагалі незрозуміло.
У нас недостатньо розвинена міська тканина. Мало того, що немає
вулично-дорожньої мережі, розподіленої.
Також немає тих функцій в пішій доступності, які потрібні людям.
Вони сідають на машинки і їдуть чи на роботу, чи в кінотеатр,
чи в Арсенал на мистецькі події і таке інше.
Таке планування міста впливає на завантаженість доріг.
Коли люди живуть в одному місці, а працюють в іншому,
між ними розтягуються логістичні зв’язки.
Це одразу сприяє заторам у місті.
У 2020 році Київ посів третє місце в Європі за рівнем трафіку.
Згідно з Індексом заторів TomTom, киянин витрачає в середньому
додаткових 8 днів 15 годин на рік, стоячи у заторах.
На думку архітектора Зотова, щоб вирішити ситуацію з забудовою,
міській владі варто докорінно змінити підхід до розбудовування столиці.
Від містобудування нам треба перейти до містопланування.
Градостроительство - це абсолютно радянська річ, яка заснована
на плановій економіці. Вона не передбачає залучення
платників податків у цей процес. Міста вже не можна будувати з нуля.
Ми весь час маємо справу зі сформованою міською тканиною,
яку дуже тендітно треба планувати і формувати.
Звісно, Київ розбудовується, як і будь-який мегаполіс.
Однак застаріле планування міста позбавляє киян гідного і
комфортного життя. Вирішити проблему можна.
Наприклад, відмовитися від радянських принципів будування,
коли райони з багатоповерхівками виконують лише одну функцію.
А решту інфраструктури треба шукати в центрі або інших місцевостях.
Проте таке перепланування вимагає детального аналізу територій,
а також постійного майданчика для обговорень, де влада, забудовники
і містяни зможуть почути одне одного.
Принаймні кияни вже роблять усе, щоб бути почутими.